uh we're taking you live to copenhagen
now to the international donor
conference there looking at the war in
ukraine we're expecting to hear from the
defense secretary ben wallace shortly
but in the meantime this is the danish
defense secretary morton vodkov training
of ukrainian soldiers a number of
countries including denmark have today
committed to supporting the british led
operation interflex that trains
ukrainian recruits in the uk
finally we have discussed support for
ukraine in the area of demining
iceland has taken the leading role in
coordinating a concept for demining
training mission for ukraine
and let me
thank all the countries all the
participating nature
nations that have been here in
copenhagen today for
their con for this conference and
especially for of course their strong
support
your participation here today have shown
that we
strongly support ukraine not only now
but also in the future because their
fight is our fight
with these words i will now pass the
word to alexey reznikov and afterwards
ben wallace alexis thank you martin
my emotions are my conclusion
i am satisfied with the conference and
with the results
a lot of information is classified so i
cannot discuss it openly but
we reached clear initiatives and
commitments on demining we agreed upon
long-term and mid-term activity
these terms are also related to
armaments production
and i am glad
that we all have common sense
that there is no time for fatigue
that is
marathon
for marathon you need energy and frankly
speaking
the main energy in this case is money
our partners know that we need funding
and they
articulated readiness to support us
financially
to finalize i would say that
light will drive out darkness
and again i would like to
say thank you for leadership to morton
and to ben and for all colleagues who
were here and were in this chamber
it's very symbolic we're also in a
special chamber so i'm
looking forward with the optimist and we
will prevail the enemy and you will see
the
liberated
uh
very very very good country which is
called ukraine thank you slovakia
thank you morton thank you ilesky um
thank you for hosting us here in denmark
and it's uh
another great success
of the international community coming
together to
demonstrate at the very least that our
appetite has not diminished our appetite
is increased increasing towards
helping ukraine president putin would
have gambled that come august
come a few months in we would have all
got bored of the conflict and the
international community would have gone
off in different directions well today
is proof of the opposite
we have come out of this meeting with
more pledges of finance more pledges of
training and more pledges of military
aid all designed to help ukraine win
to help ukraine uh stand up for its
sovereignty and indeed to ensure that
president putin's ambitions fail in
ukraine as they rightly should
i think it's incredibly important that
people understand that the fighting is
still going on and it is still
seeing the loss of life of both innocent
civilians and indeed military personnel
of the ukrainian armed forces all of
whom are fighting bravely on a
day-to-day basis
but it is also the case that russia are
starting to fail in many areas they have
failed so far and are unlikely to ever
succeed in occupying
ukraine their invasion has faltered and
constantly been remodified to the extent
they are really only focusing in parts
of the south and in the east a long long
way away from their three-day so-called
special operation
three days are now over 150 days and
nearly six months in with huge
significant losses of both equipment
and indeed russian personnel
not a surprise
president putin was warned by friends
and adversaries alike from presidents
and prime ministers not to do this
unwise and illegal thing he's ignored it
and we're here today to show that six
months on we're still as determined as
an international community to stand up
to him
and to stand up to the threat and to
help ukraine
reestablish its sovereign territory
thank you
thank you very much ben
now for some questions
yes danish tb2
yes uh actually from all for all of you
uh this conference with the 1.5 billion
euro you were talking about what exactly
difference mr olexy can can
mr wrestling can it do for for ukraine
and you also asked for actually fire
aircrafts uh earlier today and you
haven't got that so so how is your
satisfaction all in all
and for the two other gentlemen you know
what exactly difference can this
fund do for ukraine
we
made presentation for our colleagues
with our requests
they know the list of our requests
so it will be circulated among of our
partners and they will decide who is
ready to
deliver it to ukraine using this money
sorry without details
inoperational meaning
yeah but only today 1.5 billion euros
a number of countries uh have also
signaled a willingness to support
they'll have to go back home to discuss
with their parliaments of course
and we will have a follow-up meeting in
september
a
follow-up meeting
via vcc and
by then we'll be uh i i'm sure we'll see
more contributions and i'm sure that
we'll see
a a a much more concrete way when it
comes to productions of
different types of weapons and
and i must say the british fund has
really moved this process forward here
uh it's a huge initiative like why the
training initiative that that uk is now
also funding
so ben i think you can say a little bit
about the difference that the fund
actually can do when it comes to direct
uh buying of weapons and productions of
weapons
so first of all the fund started way
back when australia
and canada actually rang up and said
we'd like to help but we're a long way
away
uh if we give you some money can you
purchase some stuff that's how it
started uh when i met with morton early
on when he started in his job he said
look this is why don't we expand it and
have a conference here so it is an
international fund now
we have contributions from norway we
have contributions from denmark we have
contributions from
across the piece
that are approaching today
alone in that fund nearly half a billion
euros
we've put in 250 million pounds or 300
million euros
into that pot
and the difference between this pot this
international fund and the european fund
the european fund is a sort of old for
new
um reimbursement fund so that if a
country gifts its tanks
it can seek through the eu to be
reimbursed so it can buy tanks replace
it etc this is really about recognizing
where we are in the cycle of support all
of us have at the beginning of this went
back to our militaries and said what
have you got in the cupboard what what
can we donate what have you got in
reserves
uh as you as we see as we get towards
the end of those capabilities
it now is the time that we will have to
start basically buying from third
countries or indeed placing orders and
factories to increase ammo supply to
ukraine so for example uh you know the
ukrainians are using 155 million
military artillery we've gifted tens of
thousands of shells but in the next few
months and years they'll need many more
so this fund allows us to effectively
together and denmark will be on it with
us as one of the governors off the fund
to make sure that we're all
you know
purchasing it uh in accordance with
ukraine's need and we'll be able to go
and buy from wherever they are capacity
and i think that's the difference one is
it won't be as bureaucratic and it'll be
very much sort of uh
used that way uh and i think it's it's
we've got a number of other countries
who've said that they are looking all
going to commit to put some more money
in there we've had money from i think
canada and australia as well so it's
definitely international
uh and i think it's going to really help
target where ukraine needs it because
all of us have stock issues it's not a
you know we have gifted i've gifted five
and a half thousand in-laws uh anti-tank
weapons to ukraine
today i've announced we've doubled our
gml-rs our m270s which is the british
sort of high mars system uh plus the
similar high miles missiles to
uh ukraine so that's a doubling today of
hardware in that very key strategic sort
of capability
and we'll continue to do that but where
we don't have it we'll go and find it
okay
thank you so much
in copenhagen from an international
donor conference you heard there from
the defense ministers of ukraine denmark
and the uk's defense secretary ben
wallace there they announced at that
meeting that donations to ukraine from
that conference have amounted to 1.5
billion euros and ben wallace
said that that the uk's appetite is
increasing towards helping ukraine he
said that out of the conference have
come more pledges of finance of training
and of military equipment and he said
while the fighting is still going on a
daily basis in ukraine he also said that
russia was starting to fail he said that
russia was unlikely to ever succeed in
occupying ukraine and was now only
focusing on parts of the south and east
six months on
so a little update there from that
international donors conference in
copenhagen by the defense secretary ben
wallace